there is a new study released by the
Proceedings of the National Academy of
Sciences
claiming that one in 25 people
the better sentenced to death are
actually innocent that's four percent so
from 1973 to 2004 1.6 percent of those
sentenced to death in the US a hundred
thirty prisoners
were exonerated and released because
benefit death sentences account for 12
percent have known exonerations anything
people
from 1989 to 2012 the study concluded
that the criminal justice system goes
too far greater lengths to avoid
executing innocent dependent then to
prevent them from remaining in prison
indefinitely okay so there's a lot of
stuff here so again I wanna start with
the broad thing
where you guys stand on capital
punishment I have a feeling I know for
perhaps a regular intake this winter
a I believe you have the right
in the moment to defend yourself like to
animals
and in that split second effing at a
dues
some terrible so I stop sometime I have
to do it
but later as an actor revenge I don't
know
and oh and there are the dodgy cases is
so evil there's no fixing them
the problem with that is it opens the
gate
to a system that goes yes take the one
bad guy and five
normal good ones too and I'll take
somebody's now
and then are privatizing just start
holiday in a kiln letting people in to
keep my lights on
yeah which is what we're doing the
privatize presenting which is a whole
other topic of
topic but it's the same mentality have
seek
the reason for yeah you built it now
look for a reason to use it
yeah its its its it's like the marijuana
laws there's no logic there's no
rationality around the step it is pure
emotion
you know the drug laws are all based on
you know wanting to control
a populations do that in this is the
same thing there's no actual proof
anything that this reduces crime that
love people who are enforced
you know law-and-order people who
actually work in law and order are
against it because they know it doesn't
reduce crime
it costs more to have it I it's it's the
most
here rational system possible and
I don't want the state in charge up
deciding who's I
what this new study this means that
there's a good percentage of people who
are definitely innocent and are being
put to death
yet so I clearly for years before that
yeah right back they're mostly dead in
here
like half an hour their spirits gonna
its shell by the time you killed again
right
mean look being put in jail for life
isn't that much better
a obviously but at least you're
breathing so it a little bit better
shepper I totally agree with edit is
cheaper which also makes no sense
the butch jet that I think about earlier
than they did not should be you know
about other people up for death row from
wall street I went after I saw that yeah
I'm not sure it has got it all worked
out with and %uh strive to absolute I'll
crooks that the wrong I and II a
statistic that California would save $1
billion dollars over five years by
replacing the death penalty with
permanent and president alright so that
being said
so if you take that so if you take the
financial and go and take
before percent which is a big number
anyway do you think there's any number
that would flip
the the people that are for the death
penalty is there any number that got up
to 10 percent
yeah cuz I don't think they would change
their mind I don't think there's any
empirical evidence that would cause them
to change their mind I think people who
believe that an eye for an eye
is right is this just the way they
believe that they don't care how many
innocent people happy
I guess not but it's not been a superman
the new collateral damage Superman he's
mad to some guy knocked his mom over so
goes to three apartment buildings you
know blows
one aimed at now the other people at my
kids Crayola
you know whatever you did something to
me personally about this is burst crash
Bang
that kinda made of people having to make
killed I just how much did you just see
the appeal to charity does not go over
buildings
corn silage ruining life that shot the
former was born so about after
I'm sorry betsy meritcare paragraph and
them mentality
that mentality is the same thing as a I
am
you know we're doing this for your own
good liar you gotta die for her home got
a lot of the innocents have to do to
protect you
it's becoming evident it's a broken soul
sister estimate thinking
yet as we know the culture wars right
now is
Old Testament verses rational science
people
that's where we are in america for
thirty years and it's its heating up now
and but it just because I become so
obvious
you know when you look at just the
numbers and then today
out last night of course in oklahoma
yeah
a horrific horrific big went to execute
this man and they've got new medicine
and a he woke up and he was tracking
everything in the butt Ameritech forty
minutes later really like
do we think that maybe that qualifies as
cruel and unusual with and you know if
the death penalty was so good maybe
they would have to do that thing where
the people that or press the button at
one so you don't know who actually did
it for the firing squad right where some
other people have blacks because they
don't want to leave with
sober really okay you it seem to be able
to find more people
willing to to actually kill them yeah I
know it's it and then
the fact that she's she's not stopping
executions in her state they're just
gonna wait two weeks and try to sort
this out yeah
because that could probably bad are
going to pay bottle what do we do know
me
a what do we do to reform somebody's
people could yet there are the people
maybe the Hannibal Lecter is
you know that really head be reformed
River put back into society
but we have plenty of people that go to
jail for life for good job perhaps their
lives that
that can be reformed anything that we
make people more hardened criminals
when it actually help institutionalism
what happens
in those walls and those prisons each
changes people they go from humans to
animals a
I was just watching a front line the
other night a about
a solitary confinement and it it
dehumanize these people to the point
where
I can imagine them ever functioning
outside as well as again I don't know
what the answer is it's it and get you
know that's a former
torture yeah and do what they do to
america
a lot of torture stops happening
americans all time yeah
lot more and more and more like against
all treaties everywhere
yeah when we closing that gap both know
what happened orgy what happened to
president what right do what we thought
was the guy that said it doesn't give me
an option
where at the weird name bright yeah